we're talking about the transgender
issue all the time in women's history
month now I guess uh I guess women's
History Month celebrates men who think
that they're women there is a point that
an Olympic Athlete just made her name is
Sharon Davies former British Olympic
swimmer
I celebrated this decision by the world
Athletics to ban the trans identifying
athletes from women's events publicly
thanking the organization's president
a Sebastian Co and here's what she said
she said women are not a testosterone
level
this was always a bogus argument and
should never have been considered a
waste of time and money male biology
a male biology Advantage is uh real it
cannot be fully mitigated against
females of all ages and all sports or
deserving a fair safe sport as much as
males get no one's banned from sport
just just a category they don't qualify
for
I have heard a lot of conservatives say
look what are we going to do with the
transgender thing let's just we'll just
test people's testosterone if you've got
too much testosterone then you've got to
compete with the men and then if you
don't have enough testosterone you
compete with the women
no
guys yes some people have more
testosterone than others not every man
is just a brimming
with virility and testosterone like some
of us here okay some people are at a
disadvantage in that regard
but they can still be men
are not just testosterone
women are not just estrogen to accept
the testosterone levels standard for
sports is to accept transgenderism
is to accept the idea that men and women
are either entirely reducible to their
bodies or not at all reducible to their
bodies
which is which is what they say
the transgenderists hold both views
they'll say hey if I chop my
Family Jewels off and I get prosthetic
breasts and I put on a wig and I put on
a dress I am really a woman if I have
the appearances of a woman then I really
am a woman or they'll say no it doesn't
matter I could have a big beard I could
be big Husky Hank walking into the
women's locker room but if I think that
I'm a woman then I'm a woman
but both of those views are not correct
because human beings are not just body
and we're not just not body
we're Body and Soul together
the body is our material self the soul
is the substantial form of our body
sex derives from the body from our
natural
body
and it applies to the whole person as an
Inseparable accident that persists as
long as the individual exists we just
are
we just are a man
or we are a woman
and you if Sports in many ways even male
Sports you're you're judging how manly a
man is and the manly or men are going to
beat the less manly men in a lot of
sports
well the less manly men are still men
and a lot of the point of the sport is
to figure out who's the best competitor
women are not just estrogen they're not
a testosterone level
women are a real category
a real natural category and no amount of
tinkering and scientific Witchcraft and
ideological Jumping Jacks and
somersaults none of that is going to
change what a man is and what a woman is
you saw another example of this
absurdity over the weekend some dude won
a women's cycling event I believe in New
York
photo was going around the internet
you see that down there on the number
three
spot you see some woman holding her
trophy in the air whatever I guess a
bottle of champagne then on the number
two spot you see another woman smiling
she's got her bottle of champagne and
then on the number one spot is a big
hulking dude both arms in the air with a
bottle of champagne
and if I were the husband of the number
two woman I would be really really angry
at the dude in the number one spot
because you're looking at this picture
and you you look and you think oh that
number two woman yeah she did a good job
but she just wasn't yeah she wasn't the
best but she actually was the best woman
in the race and she deserves to be in
the number one spot
and I don't know if there was a prize
associated with this
very often the the arguments against men
competing in women's sports is is that
well the men could take the women's
scholarships you know there's a real
Financial harm that's done here to women
when the men get to compete or the the
men could get into college
there's a real uh you know harm
educational harm to the women here
because the guy could take the the spot
at the college
but even just the glory of the thing
even why do people engage in Recreation
and Leisure in sports part of it is just
for the glory for excellence to
demonstrate excellence and and so that
that other people can Marvel at that
excellence and that woman was robbed of
her rightful place by a very confused
man a very disturbed man that we are all
indulging and that's just it's just
wrong
even as a matter of
celebration and Sport
and Glory
okay it is it is a non-sequitur that if
a guy just chops off a body part or
takes some estrogen or something that he
becomes a woman speaking of
non-sequiturs
we love
on the right we love when a liberal
seems a little bit more conservative and
so everybody is fawning over Bill Maher
and I kind of like Bill Maher did a bit
on his show the other day about me after
my seat back speech it was pretty funny
I get generally get a kick out of Bill
Maher but Bill Maher
Bill Moore has this problem where he
he'll make a good point
and then totally undercut his point he
just did that on the religion of climate
change
all right so um we had yet another one
of those reports this week from the U.N
Intergalactic panel on climate or that's
not the real name of it but it's
something like that I feel like I to
talk about Groundhog Day I feel like
I've written written I've read this
report
every year
and it's always the same the world is
coming to an end which I think it is by
the way I I think disaster is coming but
they always seem to predict very
specifically when and some of those
dates have already passed I think they
should first of all stop doing that you
know because it really bleeds their
credibility it's kind of like what the
Western Medical establishment found out
about covid don't lie about it
people you will lose their credibility
yeah right they don't have credibility
anymore the the Western Medical
establishment burned their credibility
during covid the sky is going to fall
climate people have burned their
credibility for 50 years now because all
their doomsday predictions keep being
proven false
and yet
Bill Maher says and I think the world is
ending yeah I think they're right
you know I think they're right
ultimately but they're just they're
tarnishing a lot of their credibility so
it's just they need to stop they need to
be more cautious
well I thought Bill Maher was The
Logical guy I mean I never thought Bill
Murray was The Logical guy but he
presents himself as I'm the rational guy
I'm The Logical guy
I'm an atheist I just follow the science
what's he say he says well
all the evidence says the world isn't
ending all the people claiming the world
is ending have been proving been proven
wrong time and time again that all the
people who claim the world is ending
have been proven wrong even on other
predictions they've made not related to
their claims about the world ending
but I still believe the world is ending
this
is cognitive dissonance
of the highest caliber
but it's much easier
for these liberals
to convince themselves of something that
they had previously just they just
immediately admitted was not true
they can convince themselves to continue
to believe in it
more easily than they can convince
themselves to change their behavior and
decease to be liberals
they just can't it's so devastating I
remember as I became more and more
conservative than I previously had been
I remember thinking man it must be
really it is really hard to give up
liberalism because liberalism defines
our whole political order or at least
has for a long time now and to give that
up and to say wow it's wrong the
predictions they make are wrong the
things they say about human nature are
wrong they now say men or women and
women are men it was wrong the things
they say about the human person the
things they say about society and what
it's all it's just wrong they're just
wrong
and they don't have credibility so when
people keep getting things wrong and
they don't have credibility you know
what you got to do you got to stop
listening to them and start listening to
people who make more sense
that's what we do over on the
Nostradamus membrane segmentum okay we
talk to people who make sense they crème
de La Creme if you're part of the Hawaii
paloi here on YouTube get on over to
daily wire go to dailywire.com Knowles
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
all right